[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys
wells heute stelle ich mich endlich eure
herausforderung und werde heute mich der
challenge annehmen ich habe euch vor
kurzem gefragt ob ihr eine
herausforderung für mich sieht ob wir
was hat was ich mal packen soll es darf
gerne ausgefallen seien und ihr habt mir
ganz ganz viele kommentare geschrieben
über die verschiedensten plattformen
es kamen viele sachen zusammen die ich
vielleicht heute nicht machen kann wie
zum beispiel eine fünfstöckige
hochzeitstorte für eine türkische
hochzeit mit fünf verschiedenen ebenen
und sehr komischen zutaten wie zum
beispiel gurke oder curry hatten wir
noch nie kommt wir machen jetzt echt
eine challenge an milch die ich dann
versuche zu meistern die dann vielleicht
zum bug trend wird weil ihr sie zu hause
nachmachen können das heißt es war so
ein community ding und ich habe gesagt
macht alle mit also bin ich schon dafür
dass ich etwas auswählen was ihr eben
auch zu hause nachmachen können deswegen
also meine wahl habe ich getroffen und
zwar habe ich hier gelesen und das hat
mich an anderen ist er erinnert was ich
schon mal gegessen habe und zwar deshalb
ist schon wieder nett wo ist es denn
hier
ein 3d schoko baum mit zuckerwatte und
ich habe tatsächlich so war es vor ein
paar jahren mit ella entdeckt mit ella
unserm ihrer da waren wir nämlich im
freizeitpark efteling und haben da da
gibt es diesen großen sprechenden baum
und den haben sie praktisch als dessert
auf ihrer karte und ich kann nicht mal
da auch im bild zeigen geht es dort
aussah wobei ich im kopf jetzt ein
bisschen was anderes habe weil das doch
sehr kindlich aussieht und ich finde das
darf jetzt schon ein bisschen anders
aussehen guckt mal und das war praktisch
sonntag obendrauf zuckerwatte und und
anne kremer und ich habe mir jetzt
überlegt dass ich das ganze als
erwachsenen des erbacher also so ein
bisschen erwachsener nicht verbindlich
und mir zu verschiedenen komponenten ich
glaube ich das nicht ein bisschen zu
inspirieren von unserem freund vom
tristan brandt der hat eine sterneküche
und jetzt mache ich mal so sterneküche
für zuhause ich hoffe der tristan dachte
ich da nicht aus ständige hierfür zu
hause mit dingen die man überall im
supermarkt bekommt challenge okay ich
überlege mir das jetzt erst wie es
machen möchte was ich alles dazu brauche
und dann zeige ich euch die zutaten und
zeigt euch was ich zuerst mal los
so funktioniert okay einen baum
und darunter hätte ich gern so ein
bisschen erde aus schoko crumble
[Musik]
und auf den baum noch zuckerwatte und
ich habe jetzt noch eine zuckerwatte
maschine bestellt weil es glaube ich
recht cool aussieht aber ich habe auch
zuckerwatte gekauft hast du dir gucken
ist einfach wie wir das machen ich
glaube das passt ich mache jetzt erstmal
krampe
für die streusel nämlich 100 gramm
butter jeweils 50 gramm weißen zucker
und kokos blüten zucker etwas salz 200
kamel da hab ich jetzt ein dinkelmehl
weizen geht aber auch 50 gramm cacau
etwas tanker passte rund 50 gramm
haselnüsse die sind bereits gerüstet und
gehackt ich glaube cacau kann vielleicht
ein bisschen zu viel sein ich probier's
einfach gleich wichtig ist dass die
butter kalt ist wenn sie warm ist dann
solltet ihr einfach die streusel später
kurz im kühlschrank stellen bevor er sie
in den ofen gibt okay dann gibt's direkt
los da kommen nämlich eigentlich alle
zutaten hier schon mal rein und jetzt
hier zucker cocos blüten zucker dazu den
nehme ich jetzt dazu weil das ganze so
ein bisschen mal sicher und karamell
geschmeckt und das ist ganz gut ich
glaube das passt einfach schön salz ist
immer ganz wichtig verrührt das erst mal
ganz kurz
[Musik]
ok sieht schonmal gut aus jetzt kommen
die restlichen zutaten dazu wie gesagt
gebe ich mal nicht mal die hälfte des
kakaos dazu und habe ja eine waage
kann ich das hier
ja manchmal so 20 da etwas tanklaster
dann hier auch nochmal kurz berühren
[Musik]
ja
ich gebe jetzt tatsächlich ein schluck
wasser dazu weil ich ja jetzt dinkelmehl
verwendet habe wenn ihr weizenmehl
verwendet brauchte es nicht denn
dinkelmehl sieht so ein bisschen mehr
flüssigkeit ich muss aber alles ganz
exakt für euch ab damit er dass man da
machen könnt es ist schon noch sehr
bröselig aber ich glaub dem zweck
erfüllt weil normale freunde sind ja so
ein bisschen größer ich will aber dass
es wie er da aus sind segen
sagt jetzt noch
aber das wird schon
[Musik]
das ist so darf dem maße jetzt aus zehn
schön krümelig falls noch gutes
stückchen da sein sollten falls ihr es
mit der hand verknetet dann findet doch
immer schön so ein bisschen reiben dann
spürt man das nämlich auch aber hier ist
alles perfekt vermengt ok ich gebe es
hier aber noch ein paar haselnüsse dazu
die dürfen nämlich nochmal mit resten
jetzt einfach schön verteilt
und im ofen backen
[Musik]
die kumpel sind noch immer offen ich
habe jetzt hier schon mal die zutaten
für die fruchtige komponente und nehme
jetzt hier 200 gramm himbeeren und 200
gramm kirschen beides aus dem
tiefkühlfach 50 g zucker etwas zimt
zitronensaft und wasser ich glaube die
challenger ich war ja auch so ein
bisschen bereite alles in der kämpfe das
haben ganz viele geschrieben das mache
ich jetzt auch ihr könnt es jetzt auf
eine auf dem herd kochen im topf oder
eben in der küchenmaschine alle zutaten
rhein geben
und dann kann ich jetzt hier einfach das
ganze aufkochen lassen 100 grad ein
bisschen rühren oder wie gesagt einfach
im kochtopf
[Musik]
das sollte jetzt erstmal reichen
mein gott sieht aus wie marmelade ist
ein prinzip der monat einfach und
die könnte jetzt gerne entweder pürieren
oder auch so belassen
ich lass das so ich finde es einfach
hier rein
die streusel sind mittlerweile auch
fertig was ich auch abkühlen und ich
glaube jetzt
sagen uns schon mal dran jetzt werden
wir quartiere temperieren ich bereite es
mal kurz vor
und weil wenn deshalb nicht funktioniert
dann kommen wir unseren kader stehen sie
auch sparen tja dann nehmt ihr euch
jetzt eure lieblingsschokolade ich bin
ja so ein zar peter venn und ich finde
das passt jetzt auch ganz gut aber falls
ihr vollmilch bevorzugt dann eben
einfach vollmilch oder auch gern weiße
schokolade
besser ist es wenn jetzt kuvertüre nimmt
weil die einfach auch schon fest wird
und wichtig ist hier dass die kuvertüre
temperiert also vor kristallisiert wird
was ihr hier immer ganz gut auf der
verpackung weil callebaut muss ich sagen
ablesen könnte dass man eben kuvertüre
erst mal erwärmt auf einen bestimmten
punkt und dann wieder mit fester
kuvertüre unterkühlt also die kuvertüre
praktisch impft hat nichts mehr impfen
zu tun sondern heißt einfach schokolade
impfen mit fester quartiere aber wie
gesagt da mache ich ja auch noch mal
einen schokoladen basic video für euch
weil das schon so ein bisschen eine
kleine wissenschaft ist und es könnte
jetzt entweder über dem warmen wasserbad
oder in der mikrowelle oder tatsächlich
auch in der kenwood da entscheidet ihr
einfach los für euch um ein wandelndes
ich mach das jetzt hier es gibt sogar
ein programm dafür tatsächlich dass man
das machen kann das zeige ich euch mal
das habe ich euch auch noch nie gezeigt
daher kann man hier so ein schnee
schlagen biskuit teig kneten schweizer
beese und so weiter oder eben schokolade
[Musik]
und jetzt ist die kuvertüre geschmolzen
das waren jetzt zwei dritteln es dann
von der hitze runter und dann kommt noch
mal das restliche drittel dazu von mir
also 250 gramm
und dann einfach ohne wärme nochmal
verrühren lassen
[Musik]
wollen wir ganz kurz eine schokoladen
probe das heißt einmal detail karte
verwenden wenn ihr denkt dass die
kuvertüre jetzt gut ist und keine
kleinen stückchen mehr drin sind
wir dann auch ganz gut dann einmal kurz
vor einer spitze eintauchen und auf die
arbeitsfläche legen und wenn es bei
raumtemperatur innerhalb einer minute
ungefähr schon fest wird und glänzt dann
ist sie gut und ich bereits schon mein
eis wasser vor
[Musik]
die kuvertüre passt also ist nehmt euch
entweder einen spritzbeutel oder einfach
eine gefriertruhe das geht auch dabei
der gefriertruhe könnt ihr nämlich
darauf achten dass ihr praktisch die
ecke mit der schokolade füllt und
spritzbeutel ist natürlich einfacher
weil der schon eine schöne spitze hat um
so eine ecke gehört da oben eine kleine
spitze wegschneiden
ja normalerweise bewegt das eiswasser
jetzt dass man da quasi nach vorn rein
spritzen kann und dann
wird inhaltlich fest ok ich brauche
jetzt erst mal hat die erste idee ich
probiere jetzt erstmal so ein
zweidimensionalen baum und dann noch
einen und das so aneinander
managerin so ein bisschen zu dünn
[Musik]
der schnipsel immer schön merkt dass die
nicht messen landen
ich habe nur angst dass es noch
kindergarten aussieht
jetzt ist echt gut wenn da so ein
bisschen nach unten sinkt
[Musik]
ihr seht schon die eiswürfel die helfen
ja dabei also es wird jetzt nicht
reichen nur eiskaltes wasser zu nehmen
die eiswürfel halten ja sozusagen die
form und dadurch dass die eben
unterschiedlich groß sind hat ja die
schokolade den platz um sich darauf ab
zu stützen
[Musik]
die bäume haben funktioniert ich habe es
jetzt im kühlschrank zwischengelagert
und ich hab jetzt überlegt als creme als
cremige konsistenz und komponente wollte
sagen komponente mache ich jetzt eine
mousse au chocolat und das ist jetzt
einfach das klassische rezept von meinem
blog dafür nämlich 200 km steif
geschlagene sahne 200 gramm kuvertüre
dies bereits geschmolzen 50 gramm sahne
einen heißen espresso der hat 50
milliliter 50 gramm zucker etwas salz
und hier habe ich noch vier eier und die
sind bereits getrennt genau und jetzt
gebe ich schon mal das eiweiß in die
rührschüssel jetzt einfach drauf achten
dass es frische eier sind weil sie ihr
trikot auch weiter verwendet werden
prise salz dazu
und während des schlagens einfach den
zucker schön einrieseln lassen
[Musik]
so sieht's schon perfekt aus es darf so
so leicht ich mag das wort nicht so
leicht schließlich aussehen genau dann
ist es gut
und dann kurz zur seite stellen und
jetzt habe ich hier die flüssige
kuvertüre
da kommt jetzt der espresso dazu
ihr könnt auch so machen dass ihr den
espresso mit der sahne erwärmt und dann
die schokolade so gibt und dann schmilzt
er auch da drin sein noch dazu
perfekt
jetzt gebe ich einfach die vier eigelbe
hier rein die schoko sahne direkt
hinterher
jetzt schön cremig verrührt
ich habe ich hier die schokocreme und da
habe ich jetzt vorsichtig den eischnee
unter und die sahne und zwar beides im
wechsel
erst mal bisschen
einschläfern
[Musik]
dann fühle ich dass hier
einfach schön um in ein flaches gefäß
damit eben auch schön kalt wird
normalerweise würde ich jetzt die mousse
au chocolat zum beispiel in einzelne
gläser füllen aber später versuche ich
daraus so kleine kügelchen oder nocken
rauszukommen deswegen hier rein und dann
schnell den kühlschrank
[Musik]
die muss chocolat kommt in den
kühlschrank bis sie schön fest ist die
frucht komponente kommt auch in den
kühlschrank und ich werde jetzt schon
mal meine platte auf der ich dass er weg
möchte also teller oder platte ins
gefrierfach stellen und dann habe ich
eigentlich alles vorbereitet das heißt
wenn ihr das mal nachmachen wollt ihr
könnt es auch am tag vorher zu bereiten
und einfach alles kühl stellen und habe
am nächsten tag keine arbeit mehr damit
und hab dann hoffentlich perfekt ist das
gerät so als hätte ich's ja
wir haben echt glück die zuckerwatte
maschine weg kamen tatsächlich noch an
denn ich möchte jetzt noch ein bisschen
zuckerwatte machen damit ich auch die
baumkrone machen kann und dann hat es
noch nicht ausprobiert als ich probier's
mit euch zusammen aus aber ich würde
sagen ich färbe ein bisschen zucker
einig nimmt ganz normalem
haushaltszucker
und gebt davon ein bisschen was hier
reiten und dann bist du warst ohr rein
und ich meine es hat jetzt nicht jeder
eine zuckerwatte maschine daheim ich
habe sie extra für den dreh bestellt
ansonsten könnt ihr entweder den part
weglassen was anderes für die baumkrone
nehmen oder zum beispiel auch
zuckerwatte einfach bestellen oder eben
im supermarkt kaufen wir haben auch
tatsächlich wäre ja aus dem supermarkt
das gibt es auch aber ich denke
zuckerwatte eignet sich ganz gut weil es
eben leichter ist nicht so schwer und
die erste da nicht kaputt macht und weil
es glaube ich optisch ganz hübsch
aussieht wenn man dass wir so kleine
wölkchen draufsetzt färbt den zucker
jetzt relativ stark glaube ich ein weil
das halt durch ich glaube es wird
nämlich ein heller
[Musik]
übrigens keine lebensmittelfarbe habt
dann könnt ihr zum beispiel bunte
bonbons nehmen und die bonbons zerstoßen
den mixer und dann müsste eigentlich
auch klappen die ist ja die sind ja dann
schon gefärbt ok laut sicherheits
vorschrift des gerätes erst mal
ausmachen und warten bis das auf 40 zu
drehen
dann den zucker reihen ich war viel
entspannt
die ersten federn
wo liegen die großen spielplatz
ich habe wieder ganze krawatte stand
auch mit cool
[Musik]
ständig muss weg
das feuer
immer weiter
vielleicht werde ich mir zu hause
wenn wir so ein feuer entsteht
ich hätte
das gericht nicht das feuer ist nicht
wirklich noch es hat da unten drin grad
gebrannt und ich weiß nicht ob wir das
nicht immer hässlicher das gerät noch
mal einschalten sollte feuermelder geht
nicht an doch dann sollte das
herausstellen
dass die geräusche der brenz
das gerät brennt jetzt ein paar
und ich habe nur zwei rosanna gemacht
jetzt geht's los
nach einer kurzen feier unterbrechung
habe jetzt kurz das gerät herausgestellt
weil es tatsächlich angefangen hat zu
rauchen aber das macht jetzt nichts ich
habe hier meine servierplatten die war
ein ge frauen ich habe ich eine pfanne
schon mal erwärmt und werde jetzt
einfach den ersten baum nehmen ich nehme
jetzt mal
und ich werde jetzt hier den boden so
ein bisschen schmelzen und
dann hoffe ich dass die schokolade da
jetzt gleich wieder fest wird
so
hab ich schnell trotzdem noch bisschen
kuvertüre damit kann ich dann trotzdem
noch mal so ein paar feinheiten machen
als ich nehme den löffel diesmal kein
eis portionieren und versucht so kleine
noppen zu machen die setzt sich da drauf
und dann irgendwie auf das andocken
dann natürlich frucht und diese ziehen
so einer dose flasche und bevor ich hier
rein gefühlt habe habe ich sie noch mal
durch ein sieb gestrichen haben nicht
durch die flotte lotte sondern das
fleißige lieschen die ist so ein
bisschen feiner so sind die kerne jetzt
weg und dann verstopft da vorne die die
öffnung eben nicht wie ihr sehen könnt
[Musik]
dann ein parka kaunitz
warte jetzt probieren wir das noch mit
der zuckerwatte
das ist der trick mit der schere
dass man die zuckerwatte nicht so
zertritt
m
tatsächlich ganze kohle vorgestellt und
es ist ja doch also würde ich jetzt
sagen
recht einfach so nachmachen euro
[Musik]
ich habe mich der challenge angenommen
hier ist mein bisher der 3d baum aus
schokolade und einem einer schokoladen
mousse mit frucht komponente und ich
finde es jedoch ganz cool aus und vor
allem könnt ihr das zu hause auch nach
machen mit ein bisschen eiswasser einem
spritzbeutel und keiner zuckerwatte
maschine weil ihr zuckerwatte am besten
einfach kauft ist mein kleiner
sicherheitsfaktor thema vielleicht das
sollte man vielleicht nicht nachmachen
außer man macht es richtig und dies die
gebrauchsanleitung genau anweisen genau
jetzt hole ich gleich
von mir glaube ich zum probieren
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich doch ziemlich erleichtert
es hat alles funktioniert was ihr
beachten sollte auf jeden fall ihr könnt
alles quasi vorbereiten und auch den
baum so in den kühlschrank stellen
außerdem zuckerwatte die wird nämlich
relativ schnell feucht und wird dann so
ein bisschen matsch ich also die am
besten erst zum schluss mit drauf geben
und ich würde sagen ich lasse jetzt
einfach mal samira probieren weil sie
jetzt dass er damals in berlin schon
probiert hat wobei ist er komplett neu
interpretiert ist und eigentlich so
hoffentlich euro challenge wie sagt man
denn da
sagt man da
erfüllt habt irgendwie was immer kommt
profis war interesse an spannung ich
hab' ich habe mir gedacht ich mache
diesen baum die community hat mich
herausgefordert und was meint sturm wie
sieht es aus also ich finde es richtig
schön
und erinnerst du dich noch als wir im
freizeitpark und duh hat es nur
versprechen und warum sollte das waren
kasterer geld
und zwar ist es ein schoko baum und
darunter es mousse au chocolat und seine
frucht creme und ja das einfach mal
probieren weil die kinder ihr seid ihr
immer ganz ehrlich
da jetzt so ganz
gut
zu schmecken tut's auch ich finds auch
tatsächlich echt gut vor allem die
krampe den mag ich echt gerne weil die
echt gut machen mit den haselnüssen noch
dabei dann soll diese fruchtige
komponente also ich finde es nett wenn
ihr jetzt keinen baum daraus zaubert
könnt ihr trotzdem diese ganzen
komponenten vermischen also musst du
chocolat
frucht komponente die crumble irgendwie
noch so oben drauf und dann noch paar
choco sticks zum beispiel passt nämlich
geschmack das erste zusammen und falls
ihr euch dann traut dann probiert doch
wirklich mal mit diesem baum ihr könnt
ja auch wirklich eurer kreativität
freien lauf lassen ihr könnt einen baum
machen denn bisschen abstrakter ist ihr
könnt zuckerwatte draufpacken oder auch
nicht oder zum beispiel auch popcorn zu
bereiten und popcorn draufkleben also
ich glaube da kann man echt so ein
bisschen kreativ werden das heißt ihr
habt mir diese aufgabe gestellt ich hab
sie hoffen nicht erfüllt schreibt gerne
mal drunter und vielleicht traut ihr
euch ja an diesen bug trends dran
wenn ja dann lasst uns auf jeden fall
daran teilhaben und zeigt uns eure fotos
alte post sie gerne wir schauen sie
antrieb osten sie vielen vielen dank
auch an die ganzen einsendungen und ich
werde mich noch mal so durch gucken und
durchlesen was ihr noch so alles
geschrieben habt denn ich finde so
challenges kann man ruhig öfter machen
da bin ich auch ich bin zwar unter
anspannung aber trotzdem ist er auch für
mich immer eine schöne herausforderung
und vor allem wenn es klappt es umso
schöner darf ich natürlich
ich habe darauf gewartet bis das immer
probiert aber ich finde auch ganz cool
muss sein
schmeckt sehr gut
bisschen nach man will ja man bestimmt
mandl aroma schmeckt doch ausgehöhlt ich
bin nämlich auch an manchen stellen ist
voll von fielmann glauben an manchen
weniger also bis zum nächsten mal
ich habe mir ideen es waren dann macht
es so
ich mache das auch mal gerne als im rest
man habe einfach entlassen
[Musik]